[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
meine allerliebste von dann tauglichen
buttercreme und auch wenn ich nie der
fan von butter kleben war dies etwas
anders wenn wir verfallen sie noch mit
lemon gehört und dann schmeckt sie sehr
erfrischend wir benötigen 180 gramm
eiweiß das sind circa sechs eier
sicherheit wiege ich sie aber immer noch
mal ab außerdem 500 gramm weiche butter
die hol dir am besten vier stunden
vorher aus dem kühlschrank eine prise
salz und 250 gramm zucker
zunächst wird über einem wasserbad das
eiweiß zusammen mit dem zucker erhebt
wichtig ist dass ihr dabei ständig
umrührt dem lässt er das ein paar
sekunden aus den augen bietet sich schon
ein spiegelei
die eiweiß zucker masse wird jetzt auf
70 grad erhitzt und für diejenigen die
kein thermometer zu handhaben haben
extra die zeit gestoppt das waren sechs
minuten
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die masse in unsere saubere
und fettfreie schüssel
ich nehme hier meine küchenmaschine
natürlich geht das auch mit dem
handrührgerät es dauert noch viel viel
länger hier kommt noch die prise salz
mit dazu damit das eiweiß besser
aufgeschlagen werden kann und dann mixas
ganze acht minuten lang
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann eine richtig schöne
feste biomasse hat muss das ganze
abkühlen ich lasse das dann eine stunde
lang bei zimmertemperatur stehen
[Musik]
der zwischenzeit geht es weiter mit dem
lehman-crash dafür nehmen wir unsere
sechs übrig gebliebenen eigelbe und
vermischen wir zusammen mit 250 gramm zu
klein und so ein top
dazu kommt dann noch 140 gramm
zitronensaft das ist der saft aus zirka
vier zitronen für die bindung kommt
jetzt noch 15 gramm speisestärke mit
hinzu und wird noch mal glatt verrühren
[Musik]
erst jetzt wird der herd eingeschaltet
und das ganze wird ein mal aufgekocht
sobald die masse einlegt nehmen wir das
dann vom pferd
[Musik]
nein
weil man immer mal wieder klümpchen mit
drin hab ich das jetzt noch durch ein
sieb dann ist es wirklich blümchen frei
und übrigens schmeckt das auch super
sport auf streckt ihr könnt also nicht
nur zum aromatisieren eurer mutter zu
benutzen
ja
jetzt kommt auf die oberfläche des lemon
körtner frischhaltefolie damit sich
keine haut bildet und dann lasse ich es
komplett abkühlen
inzwischen ist meine bw masse auch
abgekühlt und ich gebe die weiche butter
mit hinzu am besten macht ihr das in
drei bis vier schritten
[Musik]
und während das ganze jetzt vor sich hin
wächst kann ich euch ein bisschen was
sagen denn was ich wirklich super finden
dieser buttercreme ist dafür überhaupt
keine rechte haben also normalerweise
bleibt immer das alte übrig man weiß
halt nie so richtig was man daraus
machen kann
und hier haben wir die optimale lösung
und die zitronen buttercreme die
schmeckt eigentlich überhaupt nicht
typisch nach butter kleben sondern ist
wirklich sehr erfrischend
[Musik]
die buttercreme kann man wunderbar
vorbereiten wenn wir ein bisschen stress
hat berlin von dann torte machte macht
die buttercreme ruhig ein paar tage im
voraus auf zimmertemperatur können sie
drei tage stehenbleiben und im
kühlschrank sogar 14 tage
[Musik]
so nun ist die buttercreme quasi schon
fertig aber wir machen ja daraus eine
zitrone buttercreme und deswegen kommt
jetzt unseren level kommt ins spiel
ihr solltet ca 4 esslöffel level curt
herausbekommen haben sind auch manchmal
fünf das ist auch kein problem für mich
das ganze mit zwei esslöffeln weicher
butter und dann gebt ihr das einfach mit
hin zur buttercreme pariert das
miteinander und damit den zitronen
buttercreme auch schon fertig
[Musik]
als frosting für cupcakes eignet sich
diese buttercreme übrigens auch richtig
gut und im kühlschrank hält sie dann
richtig formstabil
[Musik]
hat euch das video gefallen hat dann
freut uns sehr über euer feedback und
abonniert doch gerne den kanal damit ihr
auch nichts mehr verpasst
ich freue mich wenn ihr beim nächsten
mal wieder mit dabei sein
bis zum nächsten mal auf die skizzen
ich
[Musik]